hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil now we
just got done killing the dude
the father daddy is now dead but I don't
know if he's gonna stay dead forever so
I can't help but think once more that
this virus or fungus or whatever it may
be I'm leaning towards fungus is funded
by the umbrella corporation maybe in the
vein that they submitted this girl into
their care because the father said that
she chose him to be her father and she
already has chosen Mia to be her mother
because she calls me a mommy and that's
evident in the video that she made and
also in the drawings that were made so
it seems like this little girl is
choosing a new family and maybe the
current members of the family aren't
gonna be too happy about that because
they they like this power and also
grandmas here so hi grandma how you
doing there should I shoot you in the
back of that I can't even the game oh
there we go alright I can't even aim at
Grandma alright grandma yeah you're
looking good these days sorry I might
have killed your son not sure about that
you do your thing I'll be my thing she's
getting a bit more active than she has
in the past she's a bit more shaky
because I seem to distinctly remember
she being a way to come for her own good
but either way
[Music]
okay all right then that's weird okay we
got the dog relief we're gonna put that
on there Rimouski I guess it's just open
now am I free to go
[Music]
hmm all right then sorry I'm just taking
it in a little bit because this doesn't
look like anything that I saw on the way
in but this might be the front of the
house at the back of the house I'm not
hunt up scent sure oh man this place is
a lot bigger than I thought it would be
quite possibly a lot bigger than it
needed to be but who am I to judge
all right let's scavenge for items here
because we're gonna need a lot I am
completely out of bullets I've only got
two normal bullets left
they're not even the high-powered
variety because I I spend pretty much
everything that I had on killing daddy
and so that's not gonna be good for me I
got a lot of materials I'm gonna make a
habit of keeping them on me so that when
I get chem I can just instantly put that
away but hopefully at some point I get
more storage sorry
ah you're dang good rule right here that
I need no thought I heard something this
would be a good point for
psychostimulants but I left that in my
item box because I'm willing to bet that
there's a lot of little itty-bitty
things here
I might need oh so oh those are
supplements I need supplements pills
that affect the nervous system can be
used as is make into medicine first oh
it can be made into psychostimulants oh
and neuro rounds ammo for grenade
launcher contains a powerful poison that
affects the nervous system I don't know
I don't even know if these creatures
have a nervous system okay so this needs
some sort of red and blue key someone
was getting a little technical here and
even put a car battery on this well okay
I don't know who's technical like that
maybe Lucas is oh that's that's lovely
all right I wonder if Lucas stays in
this trailer here
I don't know but let's find out hello
boy
don't mind me barging in oh it's another
save point oh good okay alright then
time did it go through everything again
I'm just getting the heebie-jeebies
being out here I don't know broken
handgun well what good is that gonna do
me but it could be repaired with a hand
kit oh it might be a more powerful
handgun if I find a repair kid I should
be able to make that but I'll put it
away for now
I'll put these away too cuz I doubt I
need this and then then maybe that'll be
a more powerful handgun which will mean
that just baseline I'll have more stuff
what is this
steroids increase max health
indefinitely whoa stabilizer reload and
speed increases indefinitely oh oh oh my
god coins that's why I was getting the
ancient coins it was a monetary system
to be able to get those things oh [ __ ]
oh and it's the whole family it's too
late for them okay alright oh wait this
isn't Lucas's trailer this is Zoe's you
think maybe ooh what's that Magnum a lot
of kickback but a lot of stopping power
well I want that oh I want that okay and
then there's another I don't have
another tape but there's another one of
those so I think I have around six total
coins at the moment I mean the health
would be nice but I seem to be doing
okay
maybe it's Zoey's maybe I shouldn't be
looking at it then then anyway that just
confirms my suspicions that is this is
indeed Zoey's trailer
so let me just make one more glance
around for anything that I might need
doesn't look like it I think I got it
all what is this here we go
my body's feeling weirder and weirder
soon I'll become like mom and dad it's
all her fault should I run no I can't
I'm dead if she finds out that woman she
was with Mia she knows something if I
had the serum I could cure myself I have
to find out more huh my body's feeling
weird if I had the serum I could cure
myself
this bizarre some kind of inscription
there okay so let's move on we've been
hanging around a little bit too long
here but this is fascinating and I've
got six coins I could get the Magnum if
I just find three more coins but I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to find them
soon or even in this episode so what is
it you need me to do is it gonna help me
get out of here
yes now listen carefully Ethan my family
and I our bodies are contaminated I've
made us leave the property unless I get
it out and the same goes for Mia is
there a way to get it out we need to
serum it should clear whatever this
stuff is out of the body as long as
you're not too far gone okay all right
so where is it
I knew where one was I'd already be long
gone but I have a feeling my mother has
hidden some inside the old house
somewhere yeah so if we get this thing I
can help me and we can get out of here
right and so can I the old house is near
the water you can't miss it
all right I just hope you can handle my
mother your mother be careful yep okay
so I'm the only one that they've seen
get this far or at least Zoe is seen get
this far
so what does that mean and considering
those messages are in Zoe's place I'm
assuming Zoe wrote them so that must
mean that's Zoe she's infected and she
wants to get out I can't guarantee that
she's not gonna betray me at some point
and just be selfish and look out for
herself but I have to at least take soul
I was scared by a plant
I was scared by leaf yep I was indeed
okay everybody laugh at me please but
either way I can't be guaranteed that
she's gonna be so 100% nice about all
this
lock from the other side is that where I
came in no no that's different
okay all right let's go the only suit
the only way that it seems like I can go
is over here so I'm gonna follow this
path I kind of wanted to hold off for at
least a little bit but here we go oh no
I'm gonna take care of mama
so and I can also only assume that this
family is already too far gone that is
the infection spreading through their
body it's like oh this is where the
video was this is where Mia's video was
[ __ ] so it's like it's taking over their
body they are enjoying it because they
have effective immortality but that
doesn't mean it's good they're not as in
control as they think they are and
that's how it usually works out oh
alright that's fine I guess almost as
good as bullets so as it spreads through
their body it takes over more and more
and that's what was revealed when daddy
got heavily damaged like the thing
inside of it was actually dying its able
to recover but nothing is able to
recover
I'm a brave boy
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] okay BAM [ __ ] [ __ ] off
what the [ __ ] was that she all know you
don't you don't exist [ __ ] you see somes
that was the [ __ ] biggest bug I've
ever seen oh I see you spotted yeah are
you gonna fall down and become a monster
probably geez how do these people live
like this like seriously how does
anybody live like this
oh [ __ ] yeah I got a bad feeling about
that's a pulsating sack of something I
mean I've seen a great many pulsating
sacks in my day but that is she sums
alright sure I'll just fire into the
crowd of dogs
that's us do anybody any good okay so
that's what that probably is that
probably just means that I can't go
through there now I recall in Mia's
video there was some sort of what looked
like it might be a flamethrower so I'm
imagining that I'm not gonna be able to
go through here cuz it's like a hornet's
nest but let me just see if there's any
supplementary yard okay
well that sucks so there's got to be
like a flamethrower type deal that I can
get through here and this can is only
this is what I can only assume is the
old house man I love what you've done
with the place
[ __ ] it's another one no no and spiders
to God what she's upstairs don't go up
okay why is mama so scary she is
upstairs don't go up someone scratched
out don't [ __ ] [ __ ] Jesus Christ
those not worth it maybe oh my god this
whole place is infested oh man this
place is a goddamn nightmare and I'm
wasting too many things on this
solid-fuel okay so that that does
confirm my suspicions that there might
be a [ __ ] flamethrower here walkie
why the [ __ ] was that
okay all right then I don't want to
touch that hey what is this what it's
like I'm letting you use and jimmied
open yeah [ __ ] a locked drawer over
there
well that definitely wouldn't have the I
wouldn't have the flamethrower in it
that's for sure oh god another nest [ __ ]
hey whoa buddy boo whoa buddy boo whoa
buddy wall buddy BAM [ __ ] okay all
right then
wasting a lot of [ __ ] on this we seen a
lot of stuff that I don't need to waste
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] [ __ ] I should have
just what I should have done is I should
have realized that I'm following the
path that Mia went so obviously I would
be going back here and I would know what
I need to do because the flamethrower
was obviously through here god I'm an
idiot boy kids room contaminated room
detention room oh that sounds so good
time bugs okay open this nothing in here
another brassiere okay whatever the
thing for the shadow is not there
anymore but that doesn't mean that I
can't get it again I do not recall there
being this many spiders and also why in
the hell was that
Jesus okay I think I see the thing I did
I didn't miss it I definitely see it but
I just want to do check everything else
so that is definitely the thing I need
so oh it's part of the thing and it said
burner grip burner fuel so solid fuel
with chem fluid will be able to make the
burner
so is this part of what I needed
looks like something that can be
combined with something else
so there's definitely another piece of
the puzzle here and hopefully I can get
to a storage box soon because I am
completely out of space here I might as
well use my shotgun because at least
I'll be able to free up a space once all
my shotgun ammo is done
ooh this looks bad is that a backpack oh
please tell me that's a backpack oh
please yes finally
[ __ ] yes baby oh [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ]
yes how much more space ah
four more slots that's good enough I
guess I heard that nobody better
sneaking on me when I'm in this place
this seems like a safe space and I want
to make sure that my safe space is proud
of this safe I don't know what the
benefit of breaking those is by the way
ok whatever alright so now that I got
that I have four more spaces which means
that I will definitely be able to hold
on to bees hold on on my first date I
need a little more of that
let's get an ammo row going good this is
the ammo row this is the supply row
there's a spare part I don't have the
other piece of it yet so I can always
come back for it huh alright so I don't
necessarily need this right now but I've
got an inventory space so why not why
not there's no harm so we're in good
shape we got even more space which is
what I was hoping for now that I got a
backpack which means that I won't be so
stressed and pressed for supplies all
the time and I'll be able to carry more
on me ha but we still got to go back
because we need to know where the second
half of this flamethrower whoa scary
[ __ ] we need the other half of this
flamethrower I don't know where it could
be I don't know where it would be what
I'm gonna do is I have psychostimulants
I forgot about that I have
psychostimulants which means that I can
use that right now to be able to look
for [ __ ]
and looking for [ __ ] is exactly what I
need to do right now all right show me
the money really nothing okay something
over there okay well obviously
something's over there because that's
where the goddamn thing was oh but I see
something over there and something over
there oh there's stuff everywhere
oh hello wait plant [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
you okay wow that's that was useless but
what is this what are you why can't I
pick you up oh there we go okay then
alright so something there and then
there's something over here
oh this there's things in here whoa man
I missed everything holy [ __ ]
whoa what's out there oh there's
something on the other side over here oh
okay
Jesus Christ I miss everything holy [ __ ]
there's something over here oh my god
Oh tacklebox is there why arms locked
I'll take that psychostimulants exactly
what I needed
okay good god those are so useful and
also good god it's impossible to find
anything in this place okay so I can't
go through that door that is a trap
maybe maybe I could combine the burner
grip with just the burner fuel no okay
you need something else yeah but there's
something over here but if I recall
there's another obstacle in the way whoo
oh boy that's not good there's a tackle
box but that's bad
I'm not gonna be able to get to that mi
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] so there is one place I
could go it's just I'm gonna get bit to
[ __ ] when I do it but I'm gonna go for
it I'm a brave boy oh oh okay I guess
we're okay well [ __ ] you and [ __ ] you
all right [ __ ] you guys
oh I guess I'm okay all right is
everything in here that I need oh oh
burner nozzle perfect okay so I just
combined I combine this with this and
there we go holy [ __ ]
homemade frame foot the flamethrower
crafted from junk needs fuel to burn
well that is good but now I'm suddenly
in the odd predicament of being
completely full on my [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
whatever it's it's fine
but at least I got the flamethrower now
and I should be able to burn what I need
to burn yeah that works yeah I trust
this with my life right
I trust that with my wife I trust that
with my knife I trust that with my all
right let's test it out let's test this
bad boy out huh let's test that a Koosh
oh no I need to be closer to she
Berni with fire oh hell yeah oh yeah
okay well that is effective okay [ __ ] so
it's got a lot of layers it's like an
ogre or an onion
oh my god you need to do a lot for that
thing oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] oh now it now
the center has been exposed
I can probably shoot [ __ ] off
Jesus Christ well that wasted a lot of
[ __ ] fuel okay there we go but at
least I've got some chem in here I don't
have enough space but I know where to go
to get space
Jesus okay well that was largely
ineffective but at least now I know how
to use it properly yeah you blast the
nest and then you shoot the nest once
it's exposed that's what you got to do
those are the steps you need to take and
now I need to drop some stuff off I've
got chem waiting for me I should be able
to make more flamethrower fuel if I need
it but I think I'll be able to conserve
with what I got right now okay do this
first okay so I got what I need and I
know what I need to go oh boy all right
enough lazing about running into bugs
non-stop let's get what I need and let's
get the [ __ ] out of here because I don't
need to use nearly as much flame through
fuel as I have been which is good how am
i doing on health I'm doing all right I
can survive another hit well I've got
two chem storage right here I know I'm
gonna use a strong one to make strong
bullets extract bullets and then use the
other one to make more flame fueled for
them okay and now I got that like that
extra flame fuel I've got Strang bullets
and then I've got one health thing and
one lockpick okay it's not a lot but
it's it's what I got let's see this boy
here we go
we're you guys it right there right
there right there
all right no no no no there we go to set
up come on
all right got that and that's point
point
oh boy oh there we go and it's gone oh
boy just a few left okay
well got that done oh all right then
oh there's another one in here I forgot
about that I'll [ __ ] ooh
wait a minute whoa hello maybe I don't
need to kill that one because I can go
around it okay all right I'll see what's
up let's see what's going on what's
going on down here huh
any suspicious activity huh anything you
do detect okay just two more and I'll be
able to get that better gun hello hello
hello oh hi hello I want some answers
yeah I know you're right and I always
wanted to tell you like I'm a little
conflicted I I don't know what I should
do and what I want to do it's a little
mixed up right now I can't see a damn
thing
so uh yeah I don't know I don't know if
I should actually come help you because
Mia seems like an almost lost cause but
I guess I'm a dedicated husband and I
want to save her so let's do that I
don't see any other items here Lucas
seems like a little piece of [ __ ] but I
should be able to take care of him okay
his hand seems to have grown back okay -
unless you just got to reattach to like
mwah but then again I'm sleeve who knows
okay so now they got that I can go
around the back way oh nice
ventriloquist act I think I am [ __ ]
[ __ ] off okay
[ __ ] god damnit get down get down get
down get down get down thank you
jeez um okay [ __ ] [ __ ] off geez this
alright then so I guess I have to go
through this way now which is nice I
didn't want to nice and toasty that's
burning you're ready for the PAL [ __ ]
okay you're gone all right well thanks
mama
I'll be back thanks for covering the
door and spiders is that your power
because that's [ __ ] disgusting all
right
Oh solid fuel not enough space oh I will
if I reload this with the last remnant
of that okay got that
alright do I have anything else that I
can do load this one more shot and then
I'll be able to save a space with that
I've got the antique coin I've got the
statue okay so I just gotta get my mama
I need to dump this Sun feels good is he
used to I need strong stuff oh that
would have been useful uh has anyone
seen my leg where's my mower
why is he keep writing that on this [ __ ]
I know where his mower is in the crawl
space for some reason alright
so mama is being weird and she's no
longer upstairs
so that's nice so I want to get by these
guys I know that
already done everyone done being a
little [ __ ]
I brought Dudley and beat a little son
of a [ __ ] huh every but done you guys
done sorry sorry sorry sorry okay Nelly
okay burner fuel and burner fuel which
is good because I just use a lot of it
seems like a moot point though I might
as well have not done that except for
what's in this tackle box very worth it
there not be worms oh it's worms in an
herb you know I don't know if I want to
smoke that rub that in me or it's blast
that in water for hmm okay boom alright
then
oh mama seems scary great cook but you
know just just bad bedside manner oh
yeah aha okay bye okay alright
everything's fine everything's fine well
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna open up the
way I'm gonna open up the way real quick
real quick I'm gonna open up the way
then I'm going to do what I need to do
to be able to get where I need to get
now I'm good now that's open shouldn't
need that anymore I'm gonna go save and
drop stuff off then we'll continue down
the way that Mia went and hopefully
maybe I'll rescue her something like
that
whatever honestly I need uh I need more
health I am actually completely out oh
no I have strong first aid med which I
don't want to accidentally use but I'm
gonna carry on me just in case because
you never know and I'm gonna need it and
I'm only doing so well right now I'm
doing pretty good right now all right
all right let's keep going okay so we've
opened the path so we definitely know
where that is we know where to go
[ __ ] okay let's just go let's go let's
go Mama's coming Mama's coming Mama's
coming - okay here we go oh no little
piggy moment if it didn't happen man
it's gonna happen now oh that's a lot of
bugs okay all right I made it over here
now I guess that's good mama wants to
come over here she got go through all
the bugs but some tell me she likes that
okay so now let me look for any I
antique coins hellooo Arabs [ __ ] now I'm
full up on herbs I need to get rid of
some of that I can't open this trash can
oh okay don't go upstairs I was told in
a hushed whisper but you know I've got a
funny feeling I want to rebel oh no I
don't maybe I don't
I could go down there but I don't know
what it's gonna do for me that's where
Mia went anyway maybe I would find a
video camera there alright okay I'm down
here now I suppose alright then there's
the mower again bugs everywhere cam
thank you oh I definitely haven't gotten
all those things I see you over there
going okay goodbye well I got that oh I
see you boink
sorry you don't get to exist up and over
so pressing onward that means that I'm
going to go nowhere but upstairs great
and first I'm going to combine me some
medicine because I really desperately do
need okay so now I got medicine stanky
dank and a crank device maybe I could
use the crank on this thing maximum
cranking ain't complaining that means I
don't got to go through the river of
bugs again is there anything I need to
drop off why do I have a crank again I
guess is a multipurpose crank to be able
to use it whenever I need to Oh a note
Zoey you tried to sneak up to the second
floor again didn't you did you think I
wouldn't notice even after what happened
to Evelyn you just keep talking about
some strange medicine what are you
planning to do with my alter you better
keep those sticky fingers off of it
nobody touched my sacred altar you think
your father and I are idiots you spoiled
pathetic child I wish you'd never been
born
unforgivably pathetic yet always looking
down on us and trying to leave our home
after everything we've done for you
pathetic pathetic pathetic pathetic if
you ever even touch my altar I'll slice
off your chest and serve it up as pot
roast well that's that's awfully nice
I'm assuming that's from mother who is a
sweetheart I'm gonna just make more
first aid because I seem to be running
low on that I thought it was gonna be
better about it with all the blocking so
I need like the crow he is now what I
need the crow key and the [ __ ] am I
gonna get the crow key unless from
mother I suppose but I don't know if I
want to waste all the ammo if it's just
gonna be a fruitless face off against
mama I'm guessing the endings gonna be a
bit more cinematic than what I've been
seeing here but okay I've got a number
of things that are useful to me I've got
as long as momma's not hanging around
here I've got a flamethrower I've got a
crank which could be used for something
else somewhere in the house and I've got
a lockpick for
no no stop it stop existing mama say you
mama
lady you got a lot of problems okay good
all right I've been your such a loving
and caring mother he's gonna go the long
way around again bring around the mama
yeesh
what a lady what a lady daddy should be
a proud man good good good good
I [ __ ] whoa
okay she's really blind
okay but [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you all right I can use the
crank here and then be able to crank the
yank open do bad thing
and then go over there wherever the hell
that is and get what I need to get oh
I'm out of here baby I don't know why I
trust this okay first aid that's good
hello oh [ __ ] oh the croaky great a plus
for me I like me a croaky oh [ __ ] I
don't have enough space for it off oh I
can just burn off a little bit toot toot
toot toot and then reload that and that
should give me everything that I need
man good thing they gave me the extra
inventory because there's no way I would
even be able to play with anything else
Oh give me that even a police thank you
I just one more and I've got the better
gun I don't know if he I'm assuming it
uses the same bullets or anything but
who knows honestly least they're stocked
up on toilet paper and bags of [ __ ]
alright so carry my way back through I
will reload with the good ammo
alright so this good this thing this
ammos got some pep to it it's got a lot
of pep so I gotta be very careful about
it I'm gonna use a shotgun the shout gun
alright she can't tell she doesn't know
mama doesn't know mom doesn't know mama
doesn't know okay carrying on mama
doesn't know right so I take the crow
key I go upstairs which mama probably is
not gonna like me going up into a
private area but at least I'll be able
to go upstairs where the punishment room
and the contaminated
hey mama you're gonna come down here
with me or what oh right you little
[ __ ]
let's get down to business let's you not
war boy come on no no no never let's go
snap these guys up with my knife you can
surf some amaway with Mama yeah I'm
pretty sure I can actually use snap to
snap the back crackle pop
there we go
snap-snap snippety-snip come on oh
that's a thing oh no no no no no no no
mama mama I do not like you I'm gonna
leave you down okay I don't know what's
happening to her oh boy okay whoa what
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh okay mama you you have fun all right
I'm gonna go now thank you okay oh yeah
all right carrying on use the croaky
Jesus the fucked-up key system Oh
hanging babies hanging babies Oh hanging
babies Oh hanging babies okay yeah
target acquired regarding the series
serum the following items be able
synthesize serum one D series cranial
nerve D Series peripheral nerve I think
that's it oh okay then what the [ __ ] is
this it's like some kind of medical kit
probably again provided by umbrella
corporation but there's something to
this child in here this corpse of a
child that may be like the progenitor of
all of this I don't know maybe this has
a lot more importance than we think it
does because it seems innocuous I mean
it seems innocuous with the dangling
baby dolls but
there's probably a lot more to this
thing right in front of us than we think
it is but anyway so there's nothing else
there there's a baseball bat there I
would love to pick that up love to have
a better melee weapon than just a
alright hi Zoey
what do you want what do you want so II
got your [ __ ] I just got done dealing
with your mom and her [ __ ] bugs wish
you could have warned me sorry about
that what about the serum I haven't
found any but I did find out we need to
make one a d-series head and an arm this
can't be right a head I think I have
that around here somewhere you do I
don't know about the arm though have you
searched the whole house no not yet I
still need to check the second floor
here all right check it out
meet me at the trailer if you find it
where's she actually gonna be at the
trailer
probably not that's a weird e-series arm
and a D Series head
oh dear series cranial nerve and and D
series peripheral nerve that's so weird
that's so weird so I need a head and arm
and then an injector needle okay that is
bizarre well let's find out what else is
up here before we go on to further you
shall oh hi Ben whoa oh this this voodoo
doll this is one of the things that used
to be hanging in the demo in the little
room the little alcove whoa hi
oh you look friendly piano October 11th
my ears have been ringing all day and I
haven't been able to sleep since the
child showed up
it's like Zoey says there's something
strange about the child and the woman
she brought with her I'm seeing things
hearing things can't stop feeling
nauseous I went to see the doctor in
town and he gave me an x-ray what's
happening to me the child gave me a
present
I put the present in the secret room
right at the back of the second floor of
where nobody will find it that arm is a
sign of the child's trust that arm will
lead us to happiness and anyone who
corrupts that happiness I won't allow
them
live alright then
that is [ __ ] bizarre so there's some
deeper secret here that's assembled from
all of these different pieces of the
puzzle here there's something going on
here Oh what is this thing well it looks
like a dead rat whatever it is don't
know why I had to pick that up to look
at it really shove it in my face and get
a good whiff of the smells coming off of
that bad boy but uh I did just that Oh
what the [ __ ] is that the [ __ ] is that
there's something there oh it's the
teeter totter thing oh that's what she
meant by her light so this needs to be
balanced with another light before it's
able to unlock is that the case yeah
that is the case okay but I don't even
have the light the scale in the door
seemed to be connected you'd think that
I would just be able to weigh it
properly and it would work but no ooh
antique coin that means nine oh that's
good okay that's good I can get the
other gun Yes No maybe so I don't know
but I found out more about where the arm
is so maybe I can go back to the trailer
now and tell Zoe about it if Zoe is
there which I have a funny feeling she's
not probably just means as Zoe's gonna
be calling me on the phone should I be
so loud
oh mama never knew oh mama
I don't want to go down there oh don't
want to go down there but apparently I
need that light so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna go outside and try to go back
track a bit and I'm gonna try to go to
the go to the the trailer whoo
yeesh all right loading a bit load all
righty then
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
back to the trailer I'm gonna get the
Magnum I'll have a more powerful gun no
hopefully that's what that means and
then everything will be hunky-dory
loaded hello Zoe you in here
sorry about touching your bra your
unmentionables No all right okay all
right then but I have a total of nine
coins and that means that I should be
able to know know that that means that I
should be able to get this thing right
here
Magnum lot of kickback but a lot of
stopping power so if I put these in here
shame oh god I gotta do this one no time
and Chabert ski and then we have it 44
Magnum which oh god it's a bigger gun
has a lot of bite but a lot of recoil
too so if I'm not mistaken that uses
standard handgun ammo which I don't have
a lot of right now oddly enough but uses
standard handgun ammo and supposedly
it's gonna help me on my way so how do I
get ammo out of the other handgun
standard power handgun designed mainly
for ease of use so a way to like empty
this out I don't know what there's got
to be like has there got to be anything
about it
all right so whatever it either way
there's going to storage I don't think I
can pull the bullets out of it but at
least I have that so now I'm feeling
pretty good
oddly enough I'm doing pretty damn good
I know where the serum is and I know
where to go to get to momma
I gotta go down I don't want to go down
but I gotta go down so I'm gonna build
up braveness and then go for that I've
got my new handgun I don't have bullets
for it but I got a handgun I'm gonna do
something real quick before I uh before
I move on here what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually gonna go actually I must start
right here I'm gonna use some stag
psychostimulants to be able to find some
more items because I'm sure I'm sure
that I've left some like right here oh
there's a whole bunch hello what are you
what are you well antique coin that's
good you Jesus there's so much stuff
here are you Oh a lockpick okay got you
that's good
herbs [ __ ] now I'm full [ __ ] dude
well that wasn't supposed to happen but
holy [ __ ] I left stuff right out here
boy oh boy oh oh [ __ ] here's another
thing right there oh [ __ ] you all right
and what are you
she's um xem fluid right there in front
of my goddamn face didn't see it item
there what's under here Oh something in
the back okay geez um there's so many
things okay toss this in there I'm gonna
toss this for now to us this for now
I'll come back to this come back to this
whatever gotta go gotta go running out
of time running out of time runs out
time okay got that do something around
the back on the back down here shotgun
shells that's good that's good that's
good go in the house in the house in the
house in the house house house house
house oh yeah it looks powerful reload
it oh no oh no oh no it takes far takes
like Magnum ammo are you serious
oh no oh no well I gotta put that in
store it and bring out the handgun again
oopsie-doopsie [ __ ] [ __ ] eyes it
got to be different ammo alright so now
that I did that what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna make another loop of the upstairs
area because I know for a fact that I
probably missed a whole bunch of [ __ ] I
should have seen the first time around
but I didn't because I'm an idiot I'm
gonna try this again what oh my god are
you kidding me I've missed this box this
whole time oh my god in you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and there's something over there oh oh
oh I'm dumb okay so now I've got a whole
bunch of useful things I found another
coin of all things I found a lot of
herbs I found a lot of gunpowder I found
just doodles and news of stuff I'm gonna
keep gunpowder on me
I found separating agent I don't even
know what that's gonna really do for me
but I've got everything that I need I've
got three med kits I've got gunpowder
for when I find more chem I've got a
little bit of burner fuel which I know
I'm gonna need I've got shotgun shells
out the wazoo
I've got everything that I need to be
able to face off with momma who seems to
be a little bit different than I
remember her being so either way thank
you everybody so much for watching I am
eagerly anticipating going down into the
darkness of which I hate very much but
we'll get to that in the next episode so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will
you in the next video
[Music]